[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday
February 21st Ash Wednesday I hope that
you're going to church today just
kidding you heathen what are you giving
up for Lent Hank I'm giving up all foods
that taste good oh wait I already yeah
Hank after watching your vlog entry
yesterday two separate commenters
Elizabeth and Kerry Jones both said that
it reminded them of the MT Anderson
novel feed so feet imagines this world
where the Internet is hardwired into
your brain when you're a baby and the
result of this is that you become sort
of mindlessly consumeristic as opposed
to the current state of the world we're
in the internet is not hardwired into
your brain and you become sort of
mindlessly consumeristic now obviously
having the entire internet slash
television hardwired into your brain
when you're an infant is a bad idea
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
having Wikipedia inside your brain is a
bad idea in fact I would have to argue
that having Wikipedia inside your brain
would be sort of Awesome the only
problem is that you don't want to have a
wikipedia that can be edited by anyone
inside your brain like say that there's
a girl what should we call the girl huh
Oh Sarah there's a girl named Sarah can
you hear the voice of the Yeti can you
hear the voice of the Yeti she just
spoke say there's a girl named Sarah and
you really love her and you think that
she's awesome and beautiful and she just
got a new haircut and it's amazing and
plus you're married to her when you go
to Wikipedia and you type in the Yeti or
Sarah Greene you should see a picture of
Sarah and you should just be like wow is
she awesome and then the Wikipedia entry
will be about all the ways that she's
awesome and all the wonderful things
that she's done over the years and all
of her amazing talents and that kind of
thing now say that there is another girl
Julie Baskin my fourth-grade girlfriend
and let's say that Julie Baskin still
holds a candle for me which is perfectly
possible because let's face it I was a
very charming fourth grader so say that
Julie Baskin goes in and edits the
Wikipedia in my brain and then when I go
woke up the Yeti
it says horrible monster who lives in
the Himalayas huge hairy terrifying
well I don't want to be married to a
huge hairy terrifying horrible monster
particularly not a possibly fictional
one so all of a sudden I would stop
loving Sarah not because I don't love
her of course I do but because Julie
Baskin edited the Wikipedia in my mind
so it needs to be a Wikipedia that can
only be edited by experts whom you trust
and that of course is the start of every
dystopian novel because then there's the
experts whom you trust and they form the
Revolutionary Council and then all of a
sudden you're in Iran and they're
developing nuclear weapons Hank I'll see
you tomorrow